[Music]
now 6 25 on your monday morning somebody
who asked me to not use their name
writes in about that 35 mile an hour
speed limit in the airport connector
tunnels
i'm one of the very few that actually
does the speed limit buses taxis airport
rental car shuttles everyone passes and
is enraged to see someone actually doing
the speed limit and yet no police are
there to ticket people who hit the
tunnel or going at least 50 miles an
hour all day long
so anonymous i believe the speed limit
in the airport tunnels is controlled by
clark county so i'll be reaching out to
them for a response at the same time
though do have an airport connector
heads up from ndot starting at 11
tonight running until six tomorrow
morning there'll be southbound lane
reductions from the connector to the
westbound 215 southern beltway to go to
las vegas below in the 15 crews are
going to be replacing those little round
bumps that separate the roadway lanes
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone you can join the drive
and you crazy conversation at traffic
eight at eight news now dot com